Hey,
what's going on?
It's Bill Byrd is time for the Monday morning podcast for Monday,
September 17th,
2018 how's it going?
How are you?
What's up with you?
Um,
how was your football Sunday?
I know what's going on with me.
Like I felt like I had a cold,
now I don't know what I have and uh,
my wife's like,
well maybe you have allergies.
It's like,
I don't have allergies.
I've never had allergies in my life.
And she's just like,
whoa.
Sometimes there's,
there's late onset allergies.
So she's got me thinking I have allergies.
I never,
you know,
I thought allergies for like,
people who had like inferior DNA,
you know,
just like weak people,
like the kind of puppy that the mother ignores and just lets it die.
It doesn't want to let it get any milk,
you know?
But we're human beings and everybody's specialty.
Keep these people going and then they just walk around constant state of like,
you know,
listening to their nasally voices.
Oh my God,
did somebody eat lobster and the last month and then you got to like fucking
vaccinate your house,
whatever it is,
d fumigate your house because somebody with allergies comes by,
you know,
but ever deadly.
I'm one of those people,
you know,
my mom should have ignored me.
Who Knew?
Who knew I maybe I have late onset.
Who the fuck it's allergies.
It's 50.
You is funny about how you are the nonmedical people out there right now.
What are you doing?
You listen to his podcast and now you're googling the shit,
right?
Everybody's just a dick to them and get the answer right now.
You know?
Do you ever theatrical consider the source,
not to mention the of the,
the fucking guy who's a,
you know,
looking for the information,
being you not having a fucking medical degree all of a sudden your year like
some doctor,
I do it all the time.
That's why I got a nutritionist because I was trying to learn about food.
I just couldn't figure it out.
Everybody just,
you know,
at a conflicting opinion,
it was like these God damn,
uh,
feminists and uh,
the guys with the date rape drug,
they just can't seem to get on the same page.
Now it's like Democrats,
Republicans,
you know what I mean?
Okay.
They all agree on what the problems are and they're just sitting there pointing
fingers at each other.
These fucking people in,
in the food industry,
it's the same thing.
You know,
I get the fucking giants cowboys game on and there's some fucking asshole.
He literally is sitting on the field at a little too top table.
How much of those tickets,
these guys are running around fucking smashing their brains out,
right?
And the,
and the,
that's an incomplete pass and they,
the guy puts his hands up like,
where's the flag sitting there?
Like fucking Julius.
Okay.
What does he see?
A high
ranking official at the Home Depot corporate office.
You imagine like the jobs that we have nowadays.
Can you fucking imagine if you just met people from the past and they're just
looking at it like you'd do what,
what do you do it?
We'd all be saying this shit and then just be like,
they would all be just looking at it.
You don't do anything
and your wife does what?
She white like the whole fucking nothing would make sense.
You know?
I wonder if there's going to be like that in a hundred years.
Like we can actually,
you know,
if we were still around a couple of hundred years,
we could just fucking look down on people and what their jobs are because robots
are now fucking,
I dunno,
entering data.
I Dunno.
People.
I don't pretend to understand,
but how did you guys in Jab was your second week of football?
Mine was a,
you know,
I mean we lost it wasn't that big a deal though.
Okay.
Yeah.
Everyone's going to make a big deal.
I know.
Edelman's not back yet.
It's the second week of the fucking season,
you know?
You know what?
What do you,
what do you know what?
What the fuck?
Okay,
good.
Fucking Jacksonville.
They're all going to be fucking freaking out.
Oh my God,
we finally beat the Patriots.
Does this mean we win the Superbowl?
Right.
That's what everybody does.
Everybody gets all fucking excited.
Like,
you know when you watch an action movie,
you know the Rambo Guy,
is he freaking out now the Chuck Norris Freak out now,
you know,
freaks out.
The guy was going to fucking die.
That's so,
so everybody relax.
You know,
jets fans.
How many times are you going to get to the ego to let the Lazy New York sports
media fucking gas up another guy?
All right.
He said to fucking solid weeks.
He's gone.
One and one.
He's thrown for 300 yards.
Whatever.
Fucking uh,
both weeks.
Very impressive.
You know,
but you don't become a legend.
It's September.
I know you're hopeful.
I mean,
even the firemen came back.
What?
Where did he come back?
You guys were such conch.
You know what the fuck is wrong?
The jet Fed Steve,
they chased a fireman.
How long have you curse for post nine 11 in New York,
you chased a fireman out of your own fucking stadium and you got the balls to
think that a couple of decent weeks of football.
Then all of a sudden you're walking down the street talking to the camera talk,
call it out,
Tom Brady,
the man,
you guys all we all wanted to be Tom Brady.
We all wouldn't be good looking.
Be The quarterback.
Marry a supermodel,
have a nice fucking temple in our chin,
full head of fucking hair.
Mary and I already said that part right fucking way.
When five fucking super balls
get a respectful fucking nod from Montana's.
You're putting on your yellow fucking jacket,
right?
We all wanted that.
All right,
well guess what?
Despite all these fucking Instagram accounts out there that are telling you,
you can do anything you want and everybody's fucking special reality is there's
only one Tom Brady.
All right,
so are you green couch down there?
I'm happy for you.
I'm happy that you're excited,
but you might want to reel it in a little bit.
You know,
you have to have a friend of yours every time he fucking made a check,
he thinks that's the one
you know,
and he'd just go like,
I'm at the pick this guy up off the fucking mad again.
How many times can I sit across from,
you should cry it in your fucking beer.
All right.
When you just gonna fuck abroad and move on,
that's the problem with these jets fans.
They're fucking romantics.
Oh,
they fell as he lie right there.
That's the lie.
I know.
Thrown for a touchdown with a minute and a half left.
Too little too late.
You know,
they probably let them go right down in the field.
Okay.
I love listening to people.
Flip out this time of year.
You know I'm,
I'm actually,
okay.
I'm taping this Sunday night.
All right.
I'm going to predict.
Nobody's going to go around the league.
Look at the scores here.
I'm going to predict the fucking overhyping me with my fucking 50 year old
allergies.
I have allergies.
I can't,
and there's no final,
I won't allow it.
Very have a varicose vein.
I can't.
I can't fucking compound that with an allergy.
MMM.
Anyways,
when I had it right here,
I had the NFL scores deny.
Is that what happened now?
Now why wouldn't you go for two there then you're only down by nine.
That's just three.
Three drives with three field goals you could get back in.
This came with the May 28 left.
I mean he,
he's going to how you're going to have some,
some fucking questions to answer after this game by people who never got picked
in gym class.
Uh,
all right,
let's go around the league.
Here we go.
The scores here.
All right.
This is what,
this is what my predictions are going to be.
All right.
The chiefs I made,
I'll tell you right now,
I see it.
A lot of people cognitive delay,
but there's Patrick,
my homemade.
However you say his a homes.
I mean this guy,
if he keeps this shop,
yeah.
[inaudible] just shitty will be undefeated.
They were when your first show but super Superbowl for and Patrick [inaudible]
is going to have the greatest season ever in the history of the NFL.
I do have to tell you though,
if Patrick,
my hallways Wa my homes was fucking doing this shit for the jets or anywhere in
New York,
good Lord,
they would have declared a fucking state of emergency onside.
Kick the giants.
Get the ball.
Look at this.
Here we go to go.
There's still not enough fucking time left.
Um,
but this is when he has a gambling man.
You like this is fucking fixed,
right?
Flipping out.
Although I think Joey's were favored by Ron.
I have no idea.
Um,
okay.
They're gonna fucking sit there and freak the fuck out.
Uh,
Ryan Fitzpatrick,
I made a pocket.
Is Jesus fucking Christ shit to it all the first jibe since fucking 2014 this is
going to be there year.
I don't know shit about anything at this point.
All I can say about the Buccaneers is there are two at all.
They've scored 75 points and they've led up 61.
All right.
40 of those fucking points where the God damn saints.
So you know,
I dunno,
you know,
you don't,
fucking win games,
48 40 and shit like that in the,
uh,
in the playoffs.
So I would be relaxed with them.
You know who,
obviously the most impressive team in the league has gotta be the fucking ramps.
Okay.
This scored 67 points and only let up 13.
I know they played the fucking Raiders day bucket Daikon Day,
but they did what they were supposed to do.
They beat the shit out of him
after all locked cluster first.
Fucking hap a Jaguars look good though.
But anytime he got Tom Kauflin anywhere near it,
you're going to win.
They look good.
Uh,
patriots,
you know,
who knows.
I Dunno.
Maybe we'll see.
We'll see what happens with Edelman comes back.
We had a couple of fucking injuries.
I don't believe in the dolphins,
even though that two window,
I feel bad for the bills.
Uh,
the chiefs,
God knows the chiefs.
The chiefs loved nothing more than fucking fucking stroke.
And they have fans.
It's September.
We'll their fans finally get to bust a nut.
Come playoff time.
Oh,
are they once again?
Go home with fucking blue balls.
Um,
who else?
I think that's fucking it.
Mozilo packers.
I liked the packers.
I liked the rams.
And then I liked the direction the Jaguars are going in and the chiefs,
I just too many fucking times they did it last year.
Everybody gets all fucking excited and they'd pop up above ops and the holidays
come along and right there,
they all start dressing up like fucking native Americans,
you know,
the too much pumpkin bread and then the digital shit,
the bed and fucking November.
I have no idea.
And basically I'm judging the entire franchise and what they've done in the
past,
even though they probably have brand new personnel.
I still believe,
I still believe in John Gruden
despite all these things.
Is it time for concern?
I mean,
if they go all in three is John Crow on the hot seat?
See,
uh,
I know they were winning all day today and then they lost at the end.
But this is a fucking franchise.
Said he's been fucking lost at sea a long time.
I've been impressed with,
you know,
John Cruden played a great day.
His team played a great first half against the best team in the league,
I think the fucking rams.
MMM.
Oh,
the most impressive teams so far.
And uh,
you know,
play damn good against the Broncos.
Dot.
Good enough,
long enough or whatever.
I still believe in this guy.
So then today's my two sets.
There's my fucking white noise,
no pun intended to Eli goes DB.
Ah,
and complete.
Um,
you what they said when I was watching the Patriots game,
uh,
what's his face there?
Tony?
Robot one nother fucking gym.
Another gem.
Like he just like every second,
like what the site called flying.
Every time you fly you learn something.
Right?
Every time you listen to a game it Tony Romo is,
is doing the color.
You fucking learn something.
He,
there was a guy in the Jag was,
he had our guy beat Eddie was running along.
There was this,
you know,
burn along the sideline,
want to be called that fucking pattern.
And he was right on the sideline and Tony said if he ran two yards,
okay.
More like more towards the field.
It's such an easy to throw for the quarterback.
He said he actually ran the root wrong.
I don't know if he got forced out side,
but just,
you know,
Tony's also going to side with the fucking quarterback,
but it was so fucking interesting going on.
Yeah.
Because then he can maybe throw to the outside of the shoulder.
Neck still has a step or a step and a half to adjust to the ball.
If you just run right on the sideline.
The fucking guys like a half step behind you.
Now he has to throw a God damn strike.
Okay.
What is the Eli Manning and the the fucking last drive of a super bowl.
Uh,
all right,
enough of that fucking talk.
Uh,
it's still really early.
Um,
I called the my bookie people.
I pick the Jaguars.
MMM.
I talked to Paul Versey.
I picked the lions is lock of the week was San Francisco and I was like,
I don't think,
I don't think the fucking lines are as bad as that first game.
That's the thing.
When you shit the bed the first fucking week,
cause you gotta have a game where you just suck.
What are you 60 games?
Just going to come off flight.
You just going to fucking suck.
Right.
But when it happens the first week of the year,
everybody looks at like us.
It's just what they're going to do all year,
right?
Yeah.
We get you get you made your point.
All right.
Whatever.
Uh,
I picked the giants,
I'm going to lose this one and I had one other one I think I went to and one I
went to and one of the first week with my book and I think it went to one this
week.
I call them in every week.
I called the sports gambling Parkchester now I give you my pics.
MMM.
And my lock of the week was that somebody was going to get fired for criticizing
the f the woman that did the play by play and I was fucking wrong.
I thought someone was going to do,
someone was going to fucking jump on that fish hook and that that was going to
be at um,
anyways,
congratulations to frank or passing Curtis Martin very quietly.
The guy's forth all time.
I don't know if you get to see too many more of these guys.
The way they fucking throw handoffs now,
the only people in front of them now is Walter Payton,
Barry Sanders and a Emmitt Smith.
And I don't think anybody's ever going to catch em at the way the game has
changed.
Uh,
and that's it.
There you go.
There's my,
there's my fucking take the whole fucking thing for this week.
All right.
How long,
how long did that burn up?
15 and a half minutes to your life that you're never going to get back.
Um,
all right.
This weekend I am scheduled to be out in Virginia.
I think those gigs will be good.
Uh,
and then I'm in South Carolina.
I haven't been keeping it up too much on the hurricane.
I just keep seeing.
Yeah.
I hate to see,
you know,
who the fuck wants to watch people losing their houses?
I don't get,
why do I want to watch that?
Yeah.
What's the name of it?
Hurricane Florence.
The hurricane Fitzpatrick or cane Florence.
Hurricane Flo Jo.
Hurricane Florence.
Florence wreaks havoc in north and South Carolina.
All right.
So Virginia is,
okay,
so I've got two gigs there.
This is the hardest thing after a hurricane happens,
is who do you give your money to?
You know what I mean?
How do I make sure the money that I'm going to donate gets to the right fucking
gets to that person.
I've seen it on TV by the way.
You see all these people getting rescued.
All those old people,
people in wheelchairs,
fucking broke ass people.
That's what I was talking about.
People who did you get the fuck out of there?
A lot of them can't.
Lot of them can't.
Uh Oh man,
look at that.
Jesus fucking Christ.
Do you see that thing that Rogan fucking posted on the Instagram who that guy
was?
He was doing this weird thing was he's trying to act like he was leading into
the wind and it just didn't look real.
And then two people walk by in the background,
like totally normal.
I love when that fucking happens.
The best one ever is where the guy was in the boat.
And then people just walk by.
Uh,
and then what are you going to do at that point?
Is he gonna get out of the boat?
I like the camera man to how he's moved was the guy he tried to do with solid
must be his drinking buddy or something like that.
Uh,
so anyways,
alright,
well,
Hurricane Florida,
hopefully,
uh,
the waters will recede at a little bit.
I don't work.
I Dunno.
I got gotta check with my agent to see if the South Carolina was still going on.
Jesus Christ.
I want to have those fucking bankers that main off all that fucking money after
those people that you'll watch them lose their house if even there,
you know there's not an ounce of fucking guilty.
Yeah,
yeah,
you did that.
If they don't give a fuck,
they don't give a fuck.
Here we are going after fucking isis where these fat fucking cons.
Who fucked everybody?
Their own chantry man,
at least isis has the decency to go after people that have that,
that aren't their own countrymen,
these fucking bankers that God,
they're committed treason.
I don't know much about the world,
but I believe if you did what they did here in Southeast Asia,
you get put to death one of those fucking countries.
Uh,
who the fuck is the coach of the giants?
Did they get rid of that fucking fat guy?
That guy who looked like they just took him out of the fucking mezzanine level.
Uh,
wait a second.
Did they get rid of that guy?
Giant's head coach.
All right,
let's see.
Oh,
he is.
Uh,
why is it always go to Wikipedia?
No.
All right.
Wait a second,
Tom.
Further.
They had Bob Mcadoo,
Ben Mcadoo and they were like,
Ben Macedon get the fuck Outta here.
Sorry.
Then Steve Spag or new low.
Okay.
Uh,
he was the interim coach.
Now they got pat show,
but shoe,
it looks like a winner.
He would.
Oh,
they're fucking,
I went to get a little bit older guy that keeps himself in shape,
you know?
Okay.
Now here he doesn't have fucking white hair.
I don't know who he was.
I Dunno who the fucking guy was.
Anyways,
this is,
can I get on with the podcast here?
Um,
I didn't do shit this week.
That was such a fucking weird weekend.
I thought I was going to be on the road.
And then Mother Nature,
Cape fucking screaming in,
is that going to be another hurricane behind this one?
Over that parade of horrors last year they had like fucking 20,
20 hurricanes in a rob surprise feminists,
they'd get upset by that,
you know.
Okay.
To constantly named them by women's names in CG weight said we cause problems.
In men's lives.
Um,
I don't even know what to fucking say.
No,
I actually did a Gig the other day.
I did a,
a benefit Thursday night.
Last time I was on stage and uh,
you know,
I gotta be honest.
It was one of these,
you know,
they had like a red carpet and all this shit and I was just,
I saw some of the people,
I was like,
Oh man,
oh go fucking Bob on this one day there was the exact opposite.
That's like one of the hardest I've ever gone on stage and recent fucking memory
as far as like,
fuck it,
I'm going to say this fucking,
I'm going to say that.
And it went great and everybody was flipping out,
fucking enjoying it.
Laughing.
Bunch of women came up to me,
meaning for saying how funny they thought it was.
And I gotta be honest with you,
I think the same way
the mass media misread this last election,
they are misreading where like people's idea of what is funny and what is it?
Because I was in Hollywood people,
liberal ground,
fucking zero and all those jokes killed it.
Everybody thought it was funny and I was sitting there,
you know,
after every other fucking yeah.
Was that the one that's got to get me in trouble?
It says the fucking gagged.
Take a dagger.
Am I going to have to fucking,
you know,
it's fucking unbelievable now.
Like you can't even have like an opinion.
That's what kills me is that that you did something.
If you just have an opinion that does not agree with them,
then all of a sudden you have to go on TV and you have to fucking apologize.
I,
I don't,
I don't know.
It's just,
I really feel that they're going to make a movie about this era and it's going
to be like,
uh,
the red scare.
Like McCarthyism meets like fucking my space or something.
Who's going to be in it?
You know,
whether they should people consider are,
how many more innocent men are we going to let suffer?
Well,
not trying to say you can't say anything.
Oh my God.
What is this guy wearing?
He's wearing a fucking sports bra.
I am watching the Dallas cowboys right now,
and this guy just came out where in a fucking a half shirt slash sports bra.
Okay.
From the fucking 1980s.
Did he steal that from one of the cheerleaders?
It's not even a half shirt.
He's,
it's a bra.
He's covering his,
his mail.
Pictorials yeah.
MMM.
There's Zubin weigh in or Zach Prescott.
Right.
And then you know what's going to happen.
There's gotta be a bunch of people who,
uh,
like to wear a male sports bras that are going to be offended.
It'd be like,
why did you zoom in on his manly beard when you could have showed this other guy
who's essentially dress like a spice girl?
Oh my God.
Ah,
God bless them.
I'd love to be that fucking ripped.
I don't know if there was ever a point in my life,
I could fucking pull off what this guy's pulling off.
Holy fucking shit.
Oh my God.
God bless him.
Uh,
anyways,
I really am an old man.
I'm an old man now.
Christ,
what are these kids wearing?
You know,
I actually,
I should be in full support of this cause we wore have shirts in the 80s.
I never had the nerve to where one outside of the house.
MMM.
You know,
I was just too pasty.
I never thought I had fucking abs enough to do it.
You know what I mean?
And uh,
I didn't,
you know,
a few things I never thought would come back half shirts and fucking Larry Bird
short shorts and they are back with the fucking vengeance.
MMM.
It really is.
Does anybody look worse than a fucking football helmet?
They need liability.
I mean,
he's first ballot hall of fame quarterback and first ballot hall of fame.
Like,
I don't know.
How much more does that guy have to win before you,
you,
you like,
okay,
you can look at it wearing a helmet.
There's just something about it.
He looks like he's sitting between two fucking muscular people on a plane.
He like,
he got the middle seat,
the shoulders or motion,
his face together.
Uh,
I got a lot of balls considering the way I fucking look,
Huh?
Yeah.
Anyways.
Anyways,
I fucking ran out of batteries.
You wouldn't know because I just said anyways,
cause it magically ended with me saying anyways,
but I did.
Yeah,
I just did.
I just said like another 10 minutes of the podcast after.
Okay.
I was talking about Eli sitting between two muscular guys on a fucking plane and
uh,
I dunno,
you know,
I got to read these.
God Damn,
I'm going to read the fucking advertising against,
so know this.
All right.
This is my second.
I've already read these one time,
so I should breeze through these.
I should breeze through these.
Um,
anyways,
my bookie.
Yeah,
that cricket.
There's a loud ass.
Fucking cricket was,
maybe that's the amount of people leaving the podcast at this point.
I have no idea.
My bookie,
uh,
you know,
ever since I started this podcast,
people have been asking for my advice.
Asked me,
you know,
ask me what team do I bet on?
The truth is,
I don't know who's got a win.
That's the truest piece of advertising that's ever been written for me to say.
I don't know who's going to win,
but if you think you know,
you got to check out my bookie,
okay?
Remember who you're betting on is just as important as who you bet and with.
That's why this fucking crickets going to drive me crazy.
That's why I always tell people to bet with my bookie do I guess I do according
to the copy.
Trust me guys,
they are your best bet this season.
Uh,
they've been in business for years.
Um,
have great reviews online and their mobile site is easy to use.
Listen to that cricket straight against fucking bedded for the Thursday
afternoon,
Thursday night gig.
My bookie,
you when they pay.
So like these other bucking bookies were you when you pay,
listen if you will.
They pay.
If you lose,
you have to pay.
Don't ever forget that.
All right?
They have in game live betting the most rewarding perks in the business.
If you fantasy guys out there,
Huh?
Stop rubbing one out to your seventh grade math teacher.
You can even bet on the over under on how many fantasy points of player will
score each game.
It's a game within the game.
It's like it's like the middle earth of football.
My is slammed with new betters and wants to give everyone the best service
possible.
If you're willing to deposit after 7:00 PM eastern time,
they'll give you an additional $25 free to play on deposits over a hundred
dollars do you think that's why they're doing it?
Are they adjusting the line?
I have no idea.
That's fucking amazing that they're doing it.
So jump on it because who gives a shit,
right?
Either way.
You know it's a fucking shot.
One bed away from you.
Join now and my book,
He will match your deposit dollar for dollar use promocode Berta activate the
offer.
Visit my bookie online today.
That's my bookie.
And don't forget to use the Promo Code [inaudible] when creating your account to
claim up to $1,000 in free play and now and now,
if you are willing to hold out until after 7:00 PM,
you can get an extra 25 bucks for free by using the Promo code curb code.
Sorry,
bird 25.
MMM,
it's up to you guys.
Uh,
but I'd wait until after dinner and take the extra money you play.
You win,
you get paid and listen to them after the part.
I can't see that one night.
The lesson after Thursday podcast,
you can hear when they call it the sports gambling podcasts was showing green
and rang Kweyma
dollar shave club of watching a sports show.
Right now both guys are wearing shoes.
It one guy's wearing high top sneakers just to let you know that he's into
sports,
even though he has own a suit at heart.
He's a guy who goes the watches the sports.
He must be the crazy guy in the shop.
All right.
Dollar Shave club,
everybody.
No matter what you do in the bathroom to get ready,
dollar shave club has everything you need to look,
feel and smell your best.
They have amazing shower stuff,
hairstyling products,
toothbrushes and toothpaste and of course razors and shapes,
supplies.
Just to let you know,
I finally got those one wipe Charlies trouble.
They do work amazing.
The delight,
you know.
Ah,
there is some sort of like a tingling afterwards.
All right.
Almost like they put a wintergreen lifesaver and there was something I have no
idea,
but just to let you know that that's,
you know,
yeah.
Just in case you get,
you think you got to fucking tapeworm or something working its way out here.
Uh,
you might shave your whole body to get ready for a bike race.
Dollar Shave Club's executive razor and shave butter can help you.
Uh,
you might do your hair to get ready for your soccer match.
Bogies by dollar shave club and get can help you style your hair.
Right.
I've already read this.
The thing is,
no matter what you do to get ready,
dollar shave club has everything you need.
This is my second.
I've already read this.
I already had a rehearsal.
I'm still fucking it up right now.
You can get ready with an amazing deal on any one of their status sets.
Like daily is settles,
essential started said,
but you can't go wrong with that.
Iom.
Head over to dollar shave club.com/bar pick euro dollar shave club status said
for just $5 after you started a product ship at regular price,
it makes sure you check out their new video.
Two that's dollar shave club.com/bird dollar shave club.com/burr.
I'm hoping when this recorder cut out,
it didn't cut out the shit I was talking about about F1 and a moto GP.
Um,
so in case it did,
I might fucking direct TV.
Has it been working well and it missed the last couple of racist,
but I'm back in there.
All right,
back in the back in at that.
All right.
Stamps dot.
Calm everybody.
Ah,
the U s postal service is a very important tool for any business stamp sarcomas.
Easiest way to access all the amazing services of the post office.
stamps.com never closes.
Print postage for letters or packages at your convenience.
24,
seven print postage for any class male Freddie class mail,
right from your own computer,
a buy and print official us postage for any letter,
any package,
any class of mail using your own computer printer,
they'll send you a digital scale that automatically calculates the exact postage
stamps.com we'll even help you decide the best case of a class of mail based on
your needs.
No need to lease an expensive postage meter and there are no long term
commitments.
I use stamps.com to send out my posters,
50 for my tour called 50 simply called fifth 50.
Simply red is now 50.
Uh,
include your personal recommendation.
Well,
I'm a moron if I can figure out how to do it.
So can you are right now.
You too can enjoy the stamps.com service without a special offer that includes a
four week trial plus postage and a digital scale.
You know what I love about having stamps.com and my fucking house is I got a kid
now.
All right.
By the time I put the kid to bed,
the post office is closed so I can get everything all fucking ready to go.
I get a jump on the day.
If I do that and I get all the dishes done.
Oh,
I wake up in the greatest mood ever.
Go to stamps.com.
Click on the microphone@thetopofthehomepageandtypeinburgerthatstamps.com enter.
All righty then.
Um,
I know I keep teasing you guys with this fucking eastern European tour,
but it is common back together.
It is slowly but surely it's coming together.
Well,
we had to,
you know,
they have me gone for like fucking 17 days and you know,
I can't do that.
I got a kid.
All right,
I'm going to come home.
The kids are going to recognize me,
so I'm going to break it up into two tours.
That is the game plan.
MMM.
Oh,
that's cool.
Or Bill's quarterback retired if fucking half time.
But he'll be wanted to do that.
You may one last stop and he said,
I'm out of here.
It's kind of a cool way to do it.
Um,
anyways,
I will definitely be getting out there and I know people from Australia but
asking me,
I'm going to try and make something like next year.
I think I might do like a couple of those,
a little runs there.
Where am overseas?
Um,
and maybe take another special,
I dunno.
I Dunno.
We'll see.
Alright.
Allman Pharma a bill,
thanks for the semi.
Shout out to the blue moon echelon tree nut,
the Allmond on your podcast last Monday.
Oh yeah,
that's right.
I said it was the moon blue moon of the nuts.
Uh,
on September 10 2018 I was walking through my RL almond orchard listening your
podcast when you talked about seeing your first almond tree.
I live in the region of Thunder Valley.
Wasn't able to make it to the show,
but I hope that's not your last time in the Sacramento area.
I fucking loved that Gig.
That gig was so much fun.
That crowd was awesome.
I'll tell you right now,
there's a lot of cuts out there,
but all been farmers.
There are right?
You guys are all right with me.
Anyways,
he says,
I am a tree nut farmer in California is a prominent producer of many tree nut
crops including almonds,
walnuts,
pecans and pistachios.
Yes.
Yes and yes.
MMM.
These pistachios that they like the Doritos of nuts.
What you want you to start eating me?
You're fucked.
You got to get airlifted out of there.
You're going to eat the rest of them all.
Almond bloom in February and it's a beautiful time of the year.
If you and your family are ever up here,
please stop by for a visit.
Well I gotta be honest with you.
I respect farmers even though a big funny of what I've been farming country
cause that's what I do.
What am I going to say?
I respect farmers and get that douchey applause break.
You know,
like I'm some politician running for office.
Okay.
And now next I'm going to say exactly what you want to hear.
You know a lot my opponent.
So it sounds said that you guys are a,
you guys are lazy,
but I'll tell you I have and it is going to be like,
fuck that guy.
No yellow tie.
Yeah.
Okay.
I bet air for the last three days and I don't think I've averagedly and anybody
wearing any yard or you April and every will lose their fucking mind with a dumb
fucking American flag hat.
MMM.
Isn't it weird how dumb people are that actually show up to shit like that are,
you know,
I always noticed that.
Yeah.
Like what I was doing,
the opiate Anthony Show,
they had a bunch of people out,
listeners that we're fucking smart.
But whenever you did a remote,
the fucking animals that showed up and it's the same fucking thing.
Would politicians go on the road,
you know,
they're running for those primaries and stuff and you just look at the people in
the fucking crowd,
you know,
inherently they gotta be,
they,
we,
they don't have a fucking job.
Right.
What are they doing there?
Well maybe they're down there cause he needed a job and they believe in that
candidate.
Well,
yeah,
I full just full fucking vote for on then the meantime,
go,
go fucking
hit the brakes and try to find a job.
Oh Bill,
what?
When are you going to stop over simplifying things and actually trying to read
up on stuff?
I don't know.
Okay.
Wouldn't a lot of the charm or the podcast be gone if I did that,
you know,
is,
is it me or is the sound of that cricket?
Fucking definitely.
It's like it's in here.
It's like,
it's slowly sneaking up on me to fucking,
you know,
is that the latest?
Uh Oh my God.
Look at that.
Two young kids playing guitar.
Holy Shit.
Did they play the national anthem?
Oh thank God.
There's hope.
They keep playing a Gibson Les Paul,
you spoiled God set up the phone.
It's going to save the fuck
the rich kid.
You know,
rich kid goes to the concerts.
Like I liked that drum kit into the parents.
Go out and buy the exact one.
You know?
Does that kid ever make it?
Okay?
Did you ever meet one rich kid that made it?
Can you say Donald Trump made it?
You have to.
Even though he was rich,
he turned the millions into billions and then he became the guy.
He,
he's,
he's fucking president of the United States.
No matter how much you hate the guy,
you got to admit he made it.
He is a fucking American success story.
Like if you were at the track,
okay.
And you,
if he was the odds,
what were the fucking odds?
Okay.
I can't imagine.
I still cannot fucking believe that guy pulled that shit off.
Yup.
It's like watching Tom Brady throw for 500 yards of the super bowl is still
somehow losing.
Like how does that happen?
All right.
So I've been under the weather the last couple of days,
but I stayed on the,
uh,
I stayed on the Diet and uh,
oh,
do I have a fun,
I have a story but I can't tell it right now.
I have to wait.
I get wait like months from now where I feel like I can tell the fucking story.
But,
uh,
anyways,
I watched that boxing match,
you know,
that triple c guy where I don't know any,
I,
I've been away from boxing for so fucking long.
I just got so fed up with how fucking corrupt it was just getting burned on
paper views.
You know what I mean?
Like I really feel like Floyd Mayweather,
the people that I'm still won't give it up.
How great that guy is.
Like it's just a fucking shame that that guy didn't fight packy out in the two
thousands,
you know?
And then we all got taken for a fucking ride when he did and now I'm seeing that
he's going to fight him again and
okay.
Me Personally,
I think that guy's undeniably
okay.
What are the greatest of all time?
Without a fucking doubt.
I mean,
you can't argue that,
but I really think these,
these cash grabs,
okay.
I,
that just doesn't help me in.
Maybe it doesn't give a fuck.
You know what I mean?
Fighting column and Gregor,
and now you're going to fight like fucking packy how again,
I,
but anyways,
but I,
I watched that fight.
Couple of fucking warriors.
I don't,
I came in and went to a party and I saw like the last three rounds of it,
I was like,
fuck,
I wish I saw this whole thing.
But I remember [inaudible] was giving me shit because they like,
you know,
dude,
I can't get into fuck MMA.
I really love boxing.
Boxing is so much better and blah blah blah blah blah blah.
And I have to admit a great fucking boxing match
is far as like combat sports.
I still,
you know what,
I have to agree.
I don't think he can touch it
and we don't.
What I like about it because I love MMA.
Fucking love the shit.
But like,
like when you watch those like this stand up game in MMA,
it,
you can't touch a boxer.
Now I know all you MMA guys going to flip out.
Yeah,
you put a box on his back and he's done.
I understand that.
But it's the fact that all they do is throw punches.
Like how fucking good they are.
Inboxing says credible.
Um,
like the,
the level of skill and those guys were just in the center of the ring for the
last three runs that I would watch.
It essentially just bagging,
just beating the shit out of each other.
And I know a lot of people did like the,
uh,
the decision and I always go to how corrupt fucking boxing is.
And the thing that I like about the UFC is despite the fact that it's sort of
like apple where it's like this borderline monopoly and uh,
but they can at least,
you know,
the best guys fight the best guys for the most part.
I know it's not a perfect system,
but there's not like,
you know,
three different leagues in,
somebody has to try to unify the title and all that Shit.
Okay.
All right.
For some fucking reason I went to,
uh,
I just hit stop against and I've got three fucking ones I got to edit together
and such an idiot.
Um,
anyways,
so I was know,
fuck it.
I'll tell the story,
but I'm not gonna name any names.
I was at this party,
um,
one of these
like
really cool la parties that you hope you get invited to.
And I got invited to it and they had Cuban cigars there,
which was fucking Incredibles,
a beautiful house,
beautiful house.
And I went into the,
uh,
I went into this room with,
you know,
the TV room they had,
they had the boxing match on and I look over and a fucking,
one of the greatest boxers for when I was growing up was there.
And it was fucking hilarious because it was him.
And then just a bunch of regular people like me who didn't fight,
you know,
ever.
Oh whatever.
You know.
So he's sitting there,
so it was like you did want to comment,
you didn't want to say anything,
but you wanted to say something cause you want to show that you knew something.
It was fucking hilarious.
People would try it to be,
everybody was like,
you know,
wanting to say something,
but then kind of like not one of those fucking hilarious.
So I didn't say anything.
I'm like,
I ain't saying fucking shit is no fucking way.
I'm going to be like,
oh,
throw left.
Fuck,
his heads are too low.
Why?
Why set it up with the jab?
Like I'm going to fucking say that with this champions sitting there.
Right.
So my interaction was this t the,
at the end of the fight there was the decision.
Okay.
Then this really,
the greatest fighters of all time was just,
he went,
aw man,
come on.
And I just said,
no anyway.
No.
And that was my interaction.
I left in Rome.
I was like,
all right,
I got my interaction,
but there was no fucking way.
Yeah,
there was no fucking way.
I just,
you know,
I just watched the fight and was praying to God.
He would make some comments,
which he did a couple times and it was just like,
oh my God,
this is unbelief is unfucking believable.
Uh,
don't ever let anybody have it shit on fucking la.
I'm telling you,
you get out here,
bust your fucking ass.
And then I'm telling you,
the fucking people that you meet,
even if just for two seconds and you have a one word exchange,
it's like,
you gotta be kidding me.
Okay.
I remember a long time ago when I was,
I was just struggling this business and I was on the fucking,
uh,
the Fox lot.
Okay.
And,
uh,
okay.
I just bombed some audition and I was just like,
what am I doing out here?
I shouldn't be out here.
I should be in New York trying to get better as a comedian.
That's just it.
I just knew this wasn't my road.
So I was walking out,
I was all fucking depressed.
And as I was walking across the lot,
fucking Henry Winkler,
this was like 20 years ago,
right around the time he was still the waterboy just k walking by.
Okay.
Yeah.
I was like,
that was fucking,
there was Henry fucking Winkler.
I just got that.
That's how fucking cool is that I am somehow
was in his fucking life for like five seconds,
whatever I'm doing leads to meeting that guy
and then like fucking,
I dunno,
20 years after that,
okay,
Bill Hader show Barry comes out.
Next thing you know,
they want me to interview the cast.
And I was fucking sitting there talking to Henry Winkler.
It really,
it's an incredible place that probably won't be here.
Look,
there's global warming.
I don't know.
Who knows?
I'd say get Outta here now.
Why you still can't,
you know,
go down to Miami.
Check these places.
These places are going to be you going to be like somebody like,
you know when you're old at talking about how you,
you yeah.
Pawn pay.
I,
I was there man.
Fuck yeah,
I was there before the waters came up.
I was fucking there.
I did so blow.
I got my dick sucked and I had some fucking crab legs.
So if you can say it like an old man [inaudible] watchos chic,
right?
Whatever the fuck you say that like doing blow at that point would probably be
like,
you know,
bring it up,
doing the Watusi,
whatever the fuck that was.
Okay.
What was it like some sort of minor dance,
you know,
like what qualified is a fucking day like it is.
It amazing.
Just sounds human beings progress creatively.
They're like the Charleston,
Charleston,
but I,
but a booboo.
Right?
And now like what?
What,
how well some of these kids can fucking dance just in clubs.
It's like back in the day,
like Fred Astaire would be asking for a goddamn lesson.
Yeah.
It's like Odell Beckham
ever since he made that falling backwards while getting interfered with one
handed,
like as far back as you can reach behind you had catch.
Nobody ever made a catch like that now.
Like I don't know what they're doing.
They're doing this thing where they're strengthening their fingers or they just
practicing it.
Like the guy in the Jag was,
did it?
Yeah.
Like I watched that.
The only thing it was as though I can't say it was as good as Odell cause it,
that was the first guy to do it.
Any end.
The big thing was he was getting interfered with while falling down backwards.
Um,
booze guy just,
he just reached out like those,
like Spiderman,
just snag the thing that moved it around so the defender could knock it out of
his hand and like,
that's like a,
okay,
that's sort of the joy I got him in.
It's like the Jordan effect.
Like that shit that you know Colby was doing like by the like they all saw
Jordan do it and then they added it to their game cause he's showed the hey you
this is possible.
What are you talking about?
I don't know.
I'm trying to say some deposit before I try and try and see how great la is and
then the back of my head I'm like,
you know it's going to be fucking,
I don't know when it's going to be.
All I know is I got a weird feeling that it's going to be all green and it's
going to be raining like the fucking rain forest.
You know they said that it's going to be like you get,
it's going to be like weird weather.
I think it's going to be just everything is like whatever.
It used to be like the east coast is going to get all fucking hot.
It's going to be a Goddamn desert and then out here is going to be like lush
line.
I don't think it's going to be lush land.
That's just wishful fucking thinking.
I don't know who the fuck knows who the fuck are.
They've always spent saying that we're going to fall into the goddamn motion at
all.
That shit.
Did you guys watch any of that college football?
What a fucking weekend.
You know what,
when I went out to go to that party,
uh,
I could feel that our state Tcu game was getting was I,
I knew I was leaving early and I had,
so I think I missed the game of the year so far.
Um,
and by the way,
uh,
Oh,
before I get to move on to the next game,
Tcu,
by the way,
it,
how,
how quickly are they on their way to probation?
You know,
I don't get these guys.
These guys came out of nowhere.
They were great and then they fell off,
which you see now all of a sudden they're great again in a Texas and it's three
letters,
Tcu,
Smu,
I'm telling you there's something there.
I'm just fucking with you.
Tcu is what I fucking love.
Watching that team,
man.
Exciting is hell and uh,
almost had a great comeback against Ohio state.
Um,
and there are two at all while they're coaches suspended.
He's allowed to coach during the fucking week,
but on,
on Saturdays,
he is not allowed to coach.
Um,
tell me you don't have some sort of headset wiring thing going on or some shit.
urban Meyer.
Okay.
Uh,
anyways,
plowing ahead here.
That kid from north Texas who did the,
uh,
the fake fair catch.
Yeah.
Uh,
the next time he calls for a fair catch,
he better be waving a goddamn white flag because there's,
that dude is going to get stuck for the rest of the fucking year cause he,
he,
he humiliated whoever the fuck he did that too.
It would people see shit like that.
You lay a fucking deal with that to me.
Then they give you the hill right there Fred.
So keep your head on a swivel.
This sunny.
Um,
I still don't understand how the fuck he pulled that off.
You know,
big time confidence.
Big Time.
Fucking confidence.
Um,
did I read them from the almond farmer yet?
Did that?
I did I miss that one.
Did that one get cut off at all?
The fucking confusion here.
Okay.
This almond farmer wrote me,
he said he was actually listening to the podcast while I was talking about all
almond farm.
Then he invited me,
you know,
to stop by,
which is always creepy,
you know what I mean?
Those farmers is like,
I love farm miles and now I'm fucking,
she had,
right.
But like,
they're all scary looking far.
Mars is,
are there.
They're scary during the day
because you never see anybody and he just always feel like they have all these,
this,
this old fucking,
they have like sickles and shit and it's just,
you know,
they can feed to their pigs.
I Dunno.
They were shady group man.
Those farmers,
they're out there by themselves.
You can't tell me you don't slowly go insane when you're fucking a phone when
you were a farmer.
You know what I mean?
Then when you're fucking a farmer,
right ladies,
you keep doing that shit.
All right?
You don't have to be lonely.
Play in with his fucking almond centered bulls.
All right,
living off of smoothies.
Oh,
Lsu,
by the way,
Lsu is fucking two.
And now,
um,
I watched the whole game.
I watched the whole game and I watched so many sports,
so much sports this weekend.
I can't remember who the fuck they played.
Auburn.
Jesus Christ in Auburn,
right
war.
Fucking Eagle,
right.
They went down there and they went down there and they fucking,
I don't know a lot of those Auburn people,
they're upset.
They lie on,
Hey,
what a warrant on him fucking passing or fairy girl scout book and calls.
Um,
I am a big proponent of quarterbacks and how much they get fucked over.
But both of those were in interference.
If you were at the game,
that one over the middle looks like bullshit cause they didn't show you the full
replay where the guy just held him for like,
you know,
10 yards.
Totally slowed them the fuck down.
And then the other one,
that guy was grabbing his fucking arm,
you know,
it was borderline.
Sometimes she'd get away with it,
but he got caught.
But he was doing it.
I can tell you this,
uh,
we're fucking two window and what's his face there?
Their coach,
the hell's his goddamn name.
I just keep spacing on his fucking name.
I'll get it.
Uh,
he's,
he's the best thing in the SCC,
if not in the fucking college football right now.
Oh,
I tweeted that.
He's,
he,
he sounds like a fucking,
uh,
a Cajun Hulk.
Hogan.
Okay.
[inaudible] I'll tell you right now.
I'll tell you right now.
We went have to,
I'll drag you,
jump to what brother?
Uh,
he sounds like a fucking wrestler and he's got them believing in themselves and
they got a quarterback.
This plan are right now,
and look,
we all know the Alabama Crimson tide is a fucking professional football team.
All right?
I don't know what the Fuck Nick Saban is doing.
How we get to all those good guys.
Our,
we spoke,
I don't know what,
but that guy is the fucking guy,
Nick Saban.
I love rooting against them,
but I love that guy.
I love Nick Saban.
You know,
I love what he's done with the Alabama,
whatever.
But you know,
when I needed to pick a college team,
I wasn't going to fucking jump on the bandwagon.
You know,
I like rooting against the fucking people.
You know what I mean?
Well Dahlia,
I dunno.
Maybe a doubt.
Um,
anyways,
plowing ahead,
living off smoothies.
Hey Billy,
fish paste.
Um,
last week you mentioned you'd love to just live off smoothies if you could.
Well it turns out you can,
there's an entire niche food market called meal replacements or complete foods
that contain all the carbs,
fats,
proteins,
fibers,
micro nutrients and everything else.
The body needs to function properly.
All in one serving.
Yeah,
I know,
but I get nervous cause when I,
I just feel like that it's,
it's science and then they always put all these fucking chemicals and shit in
there.
Yeah,
some common powder form.
So all you do is mix it with water.
Others come ready to drink in the bottle.
The difference between them and something shitty like ensure is that they take
human biology and complete nutritional needs into account and make sure you get
the full recommended daily intake for all vitamins,
minerals,
and macros.
Eh,
also most of them are made from whole food ingredients.
This is probably what the future's going to be like when we fucking destroy the
whole planet.
And the only people left are living in this giant air conditioned fucking
greenhouse.
Uh,
and they just in there with,
I don't Dunno what chemicals,
but eventually you need plants so that they just,
they kept their own ecosystem and like we're going to heal the earth from inside
here and then it's going to work on the way out.
There's another side.
I always pitched these Scifi movies,
you know,
and then years later they ended up making them like that fucking population
jumped that I did that.
You take a test,
they literally made that fucking movie.
Where's another one for you?
You even can't actually go ahead and make it,
cause I'm not gonna fucking do it.
Did you just give consent?
Um,
here's one for you,
right?
The whole fucking world looks like a Goddamn desert does all waterworld desert
and all that shit.
And it's just this one fucking house,
giant fucking greenhouse to size of Dallas cowboys stadium.
And in there they actually have plants,
they've got some chickens and shit.
It's like a fucking art that doesn't go anywhere.
Right?
And in there is the perfect fucking ecosystem.
All right.
And then they're going to gradually,
like their thing is,
is if they have to weight out all the waste and hope that the planet comes back
and then they gradually,
every year they try to expand a little bit more of this stadium to fucking
include more.
The more the culinary claim claymore,
the fucking scorched earth.
Right.
I'm already off the rails.
I don't know if this fucking works,
but somehow there's a fucking guy in there and he wants to take control and it's
all about the fucking air conditioner.
Right?
That was a bad one.
But some of the one of you nerds can figure it out.
Right.
All right.
Anyways,
the one that first came online a few years ago was called,
this is back to the living off smooth smoothies.
Soylent,
they make potter and premixed drinks.
Very tasty.
But this doesn't have other companies that make similar products.
You know,
one of the guys I fly with,
uh,
you know,
his digestive system or whatever,
that's all he does.
And he,
we flew back from uh,
this place one time and I was hungry.
It was drink this man,
you'll be full.
And I drank it and it felt good but it was,
it was too weird.
I need to,
I would need to read up on it.
Uh,
but I know I'm not going to,
so I'm going to stick with what I've been doing.
Put a,
but I,
I would think that you'd be in great shape.
Right.
You know,
it's nice and easy to digest the food.
I don't know.
It depends on what's in it though.
Right?
Anyways,
it doesn't have other companies that make similar products like Hule he'll be
happy.
He will h u e l,
Jimmy Joy,
bio lint and super body fuel,
all with their very own special take on how to fulfill dietary requirements.
It's been working for me for years and I even lived off soylent for a month
straight a couple of years ago with no issues along with hundreds of other
people.
But you obviously don't have to do that.
You could just use it for breakfast or whatever you want.
Thanks for all your laughs and go fuck yourself.
Well,
let me,
did you lose a bunch of weight and shit?
Like why don't fat people just fucking do this or look into it?
You know,
cause I figured that once they push through and get off the sugar salt,
they can start turning it around.
Um,
and one of the hardest things to do about eating healthy is now you got to sit
there and prepare the shit while you're super hungry and your body's going fuck
this order a pizza man,
order a fucking pizza.
But if they'd just all these containers ready to go,
you just shake it up and you'd drink it.
Um,
that could actually help some people.
But I,
I would definitely,
if you're going to do that,
if you listened to,
so you're thinking of doing that,
I would definitely do some research as far as like what is in them.
All right.
Boycott dear Billy boycott,
how do you feel about boycotting?
Have you ever boycotted anything?
Uh,
yes,
I have.
Uh,
is there any reason you would boycott a show podcasts your company because you
didn't agree with their behavior?
Um,
no.
Are Not their opinions.
Okay.
I would,
I would like,
uh,
if something sucked.
So I guess that's not a boycott then.
All right.
Anyways,
he goes,
I feel like you have a thick skin,
so you'd probably have only,
he probably only have reason to boycott a group that was censoring you are your
comedy.
Um,
yeah.
What?
I boycott something
when I boycott a company because of their behavior.
Well,
I hate bankers,
but I still fucking use them.
So that goes that.
Um,
yeah,
I dunno.
I Dunno.
I respect people.
If that's what they want to fucking do,
I would put it that way,
but like,
okay,
I don't know that I would,
uh,
I,
you know,
I get why people do that shit.
You just have to do a lot to fucking lose me,
I think,
you know what I mean?
Mike,
I hung in there with Trump and you know,
cause I root for the president whether I like them or not,
but like once his wife wore that,
yeah,
I don't really care.
Do you jacket to that fucking,
you know,
when she was going down to see kids that were taken away from their parents.
I mean,
yeah,
whether they're right or wrong about their way,
their handling immigration or how they want to enforce it,
that,
you know,
that goes out the window when there's some kid crying missing his parents and
he's,
he or she's scared,
you know,
and you're going to wear something like that.
That's when they lost me and I was just like,
all right,
bye.
Don't trash room in my act.
You know,
God knows his fucking plenty of people doing that.
Um,
so I may be honest with,
at this point in history,
I think it's really important rather than to walk away or something like that.
It's more important to try to get something going to talk or something cause
this screaming and yelling shit.
Jesus,
this is come from somebody who's a fucking screaming cunt.
Um,
yeah.
It just,
it doesn't,
uh,
it doesn't fucking,
it doesn't make any sense.
I understand why people do what they get.
They get emotional.
Jesus Christ.
God knows I got fucking emotional today.
Sky was supposed to move some fucking furniture in my house.
It's one of the fucking work.
And she's like,
I,
you know,
I did all this work on the house and like I love the house as much as I bitch
about it.
And you know,
I brought it back to life where a lot of people did some home depot bullshit to
it and I tried to restore it,
you know,
update it in the walls,
but like outside it tried to make it look like,
um,
you know,
the time when it was created,
it was,
you know,
so I went and I got these vintage door handles and somebody swiped one of them
and I swear to fuck I got it back though.
I got it.
I raised fucking holy health.
It's one of the few times my wife didn't give me shit for losing my mind.
I fucking lost my fucking mind.
What is that about when somebody steals from you?
You know,
it's just that they,
it's like,
I think,
who the fuck do you,
do you think I'm that fucking stupid?
I wasn't going to notice.
Yeah.
Do you think I'm the kind of person that's,
that's not going to fucking pursue this?
Like I,
I used to Jesus Christ.
Oh well there's a reason I don't fucking own a firearm.
You know,
you can't,
you know,
so that's one of those things that they should do is they stage when you go down
and get a fucking a gun license.
Yeah.
They should like spy on you for a week and just figuring out what irritates you
and then they just come in and do it.
Just have somebody do it to you in the parking lot.
Just see how much you lose your shit and just see if you should have a fucking
gun or not.
Um,
I would never shoot anybody,
but I think I would definitely brandish a weapon.
I'm fucking wave at somebody face,
buddy.
I am going to shoot you in the face.
You don't put your fucking hands on that dashboard.
One of those underrated performances in any territory to movie the Guy who
played that fucking cup.
Um,
in the bathroom scene.
All right.
Buying a Lamborghini.
Hey Billy,
the financial advisor
just might be my favorite fucking question.
Never are you going to buy a Lamborghini?
You ever just live vicariously through somebody?
I'm more of a Ferrari guy,
but God bless you.
You know,
I'm not a Lamborghini.
Guys are more flashy.
A,
hey Billy,
the financial adviser.
I,
I'd appreciate your take.
My childhood dream has been to own a Lamborghini.
Thank God.
Damn it.
Get yourself one.
Not because of the,
he says I'd attract,
but because I am a huge interest in cars and they've always been a motivation
for me.
A problem is I'm not a hundred percent sure if I should.
I should.
I he left a word out,
drop 250 grand on a car.
I know the old saying,
if you have to ask,
uh,
you can't afford it.
Uh,
has truth to it.
But I'd like to get advice from people on a big decision.
We'll do it.
I'm not the guy.
I'm currently 27,
he says,
did my master's and work a commission based job,
a realtor.
And luckily he had a few good years in the past.
Um,
from the money I saved,
I managed to buy three investment properties.
Oh Dude,
you're,
yes.
Okay.
This is all great stuff.
I know technically they belong to the bank,
but I've been able to build equity that way.
The shitty thing is because I've been buying these,
I ended up not buying a place for myself.
My parents had been nice enough to let me stay home with them.
I know that this is kind of fucked up,
but I'm from South Africa and it's frowned upon to move out before getting
married,
but to just saving a ton of money.
So I guess I kind of took advantage of that.
No,
you didn't,
that,
that was their rule and you'd just,
you're playing within the rules anyways.
Also,
you tell him a patriots fan as the wrong that they didn't say can't do it.
I don't have a girlfriend and actually don't get laid at all,
so I'm not doing it to impress girl.
I could give a fuck about them.
You are just a fucking asexual moneymaking machine here,
sir.
My question is,
should I buy my own place first,
then save up for a lambo or fulfill my childhood dream?
Now,
uh,
the reason I don't want to necessarily buy a places because then I'll have a lot
of pressure to find a wife and I know no woman will ever let me spend 250 grand
on a car and let's say spent 250 grand on her and because it made the lay my
dream and other five or so years and I want to enjoy it while I'm still
relatively young.
All right.
Wow.
This guy's really planning out his life.
I liked this also.
That matters.
I have about half of the amount I need saved up so far and will either save up
for another six months to a year and yes,
I researched maintenance costs and if factored those into its guy's done his
homework and he help would be appreciated.
Thanks for the free podcasts and any advice from Nia would be helpful to you
guys are great together and I wish I had friends in real life like you guys.
That's really nice.
Now that I'm done sucking your tick.
Thanks.
And Go fuck yourself.
That's hilarious.
Um,
all right,
well I think you know more about money than I do.
Um,
here's the pros to buy a Lamborghini.
they do retain their value.
Okay?
If you don't wrap it around a fucking tree or modify it or do a bunch of,
you know,
put a bunch miles on it.
The weird thing about a Lamborghini is that,
you know,
these fucking guys get them and then they have him for 20 years and they sell
them and they always have like 800 original miles.
And it's like,
why the fuck did you even have it?
Uh,
secondly,
um,
I don't know if it helps you.
It's not a good look.
If your real estate agent is 27 and pulls up in a fucking Lamborghini,
that would make me feel like this guy's taken way too much commission.
He's fucking me.
So I,
if you're going to get it,
I would not drive it to work.
Um,
yeah.
And as far as your worry about women,
uh,
here's,
here's the secret with women is you gotta be up front with them,
okay?
You have to tell them from fucking day one that this is what you're doing and
then you have to follow through and do it.
And don't let them do that shit where they go.
Well,
that was the,
I was pregnant.
Nope.
Nope,
nope.
All right.
Um,
I,
I would lean,
I would,
uh,
listen,
I think there's,
there's a massive like bubble being built it,
and I don't know shit,
so people don't listen to me.
Okay.
I know I'm a bald guy and I know I screen,
but I'm not that guy on TV who yells about the stocks.
I'm just a fucking stupid comedian.
Okay.
And I go with my gut and my gut is,
was a travel round the country up.
Fucking look.
A paypal.
All right?
And what's been freaking me out is the shit that I'm talking about where,
uh,
it's like a fucking Thursday afternoon.
I'm on the road and I go to a breakfast place and it is fucking packed.
I'm standing in line like it's Sunday after church and I'm just looking around
going,
don't any of these fucking people have a fucking job.
And I'm looking at them all and they all have smart phones and they have fucking
iPads and they got fucking their custom fucking sneakers that they ordered and
everybody is living this fucking lifestyle and part of his lifestyle is,
and building all these fucking luxury high rise apartments.
I mean this,
this is my fifth time around the block,
but this shit all right.
Started with the fucking yuppies was the first time I saw it.
The fucking Dotcom Shit.
Uh,
the,
the housing bubble la,
everybody's getting a house,
you know,
I'm fucking 10 years ago and now this shit,
so maybe it's my fourth time through this,
but this is,
this is what happens.
So,
um,
I think keep doing what you're doing with the money and either stay at home,
I wouldn't buy,
I wouldn't buy the loan or I want to,
I don't want to talk to you.
It's a fucking dreaming or so I,
I'm,
there's no way I'm going to talk a guide up,
a stream or a woman or a hermaphrodite or somebody transitioning.
Did I cover everybody?
Am I still in show business?
Um,
I,
uh,
and then as far as the pressure,
you're going to get to get married,
uh,
fuck that.
Okay.
At some point you gotta be like,
listen,
I'm not doing that.
Okay.
I'm going to get married when I find the right person.
If you don't what I'm talking about just watched coming to America.
Okay.
I think you're gonna find a lot of themes that you can relate to.
Um,
that's your,
my coming to America is kill the Irishmen.
Um,
anyways.
Uh,
yeah.
Yeah.
I think,
you know,
here's the thing is another way to have a Lamborghini.
You could have a Lamborghini for like a year and then turn around and sell it.
You know,
my only thing is,
is I think I,
I would kind of wait until the fucking Lamborghini is a great thing to buy
during a recession.
Okay.
Unless you're talking about buying a new one,
then you know,
but,
um,
I mean,
you're,
you're always going to be able to sell a fucking Lamborghini.
And I've never seen,
um,
well,
you know,
let's fucking look them up.
By the way,
I fucking love this team.
I love anybody with a fucking dream in this guy.
Like he wants a fucking Lamborghini and God dammit,
he's going to figure out how to do it.
I love this Lamborghini,
uh,
used for sale.
All right,
let's see what we got here.
Let's see what we got to use.
Lamborghini first sale.
Um,
35,000,
$900,
17,
900 909 c,
this is why you don't listen to me.
Is that the poster?
Is that the actual fucking car?
Are you serious?
Oh,
that's a kit.
You fucking cunt.
It's not a real one.
Use Lamborghini.
Wait,
those are all fucking kid cars.
You fucking assholes.
All right,
hang on a second.
All right.
This is more like it.
Use 2017 Lamborghini,
uh,
event the dog as coop.
I don't want to say at $399,711 a used 2007 here's another thing,
dude,
you could fucking get one.
Buy used one
is a used 2007 Lamborghini's still going to turn heads for $99,995
2017 lambo.
You can get for two oh nine five 82 door coupe.
Then you can get a 2018 Volvo s 90 for $375 a month.
What?
Who the fuck is looking at this as well?
Maybe I'd like a Volvo.
Um,
okay.
Use 2008 Lamborghini Murcia,
Lego revention coop.
For some reason they want 1,000,008 and 18 what?
No fucking way.
There's another or there's another all those door.
All those who,
the kitty ones.
These are the big boys here.
Use 2017 Lamborghini,
Evan Taito,
LP seven 54 soup.
Super vellows roadster.
I know it says 659,009 $900 these are a year old and these are all like a half a
million bucks,
right?
MMM.
Yeah.
Dude.
You don't want to spend all this fucking mom.
Maybe you don't worry though.
I would,
I would buy a used one though.
I would definitely buy a fucking use one.
Holy Shit.
He knew what kills me about these things.
If you go to,
when you go to the supermarket and drive over a fucking speed bump,
please tell me though,
sir,
if you get this thing,
please take it to the track.
Please take it to the track.
Could you please,
could you please take it to the track?
He might've Lamborghini's and never go to the fucking track.
You know that if I got one of those fucking things,
I'd have it on a flatbed truck.
I'd take it to the track and I would meet an instructor there and be like,
teach me to drive this thing as fast as my skill set will allow me,
um,
without fucking destroying it.
All right,
let's close on this dilemma,
but good luck to you,
sir.
Uh,
you got a lot of great options.
Okay?
Okay.
Uh,
tell the woman what you're going to do and stick with it.
What are you going to do?
Beat you up,
you know?
Um,
and then secondly,
you got to let go of that shit with your parents.
If you're going,
don't,
don't not buy a house because of some fucking,
you know,
pot of gold at the end of the rainbow.
Sorry,
I always have to go with the fucking some sort of where I'm from kind of thing
here.
A dilemma.
Everybody.
Dear Bill,
if your life depended on it,
would you and Chris Burma's voice what?
Rat live in medieval times as a king.
What makes 65 grand a year in the present time?
Oh fuck that.
Oh my God.
As a king,
you be able to fuck any you wanted.
Eat well live well do king shit.
But you'd have to worry about being overthrown or invaded.
Yeah,
we're hitting some fucking disease and yeah,
and smallpox.
Everyone asks this question.
Two changes their mind after talking it out.
I know.
I right out of the gate,
I was like,
no brainer.
I'll take 65 grand a year in the NFL package and I'll be an absolute fucking
nobody.
I'll rub it out to internet porn before I would go back into medieval fucking
times was scurvy gang green.
The Blackpool scurvy I wouldn't have because I'd be a king,
I'd have plenty of fucking vitamin C.
Right?
Is that what it is?
No.
Vitamin C,
no fruit in your diet or some shit.
Um,
yeah,
fuck all that.
And then everybody come in to try to fucking kill me and then just then the shit
I would have to do to stay in power,
putting people in iron maidens and stretching them out.
I'm like,
I don't want to hurt people.
You know?
And then if you're a cool king,
right?
I mean,
Jesus Christ,
they be call your fucking Lord snowflake.
They would all these liberal fucking,
everybody would think that they could get over on you.
Right.
And then you just have to stick someone in the belly of the beast.
You know,
I think about that fucking all the time.
I meant like out of all those things,
the iron maiden,
they slam it shut.
You're dead.
You know the rack is fucking brutal.
You know,
the rack,
they actually,
they thought it stretched in,
broke you,
you're a Toyota tendons and stuff.
When it actually did was it broke your bones by stretching to the point that
they cracked at me.
Just fucking insane.
Human beings are so fucking horrible.
It's,
it's,
it's not even like a eeky came,
you can't wrap your head around it,
but the belly of the beast,
you know,
that expression being in the belly of the beast,
they would actually have like some giant looking bolusing
made out of cast iron or something and they would put you in there,
close it and then light of fire underneath and basically cookie will live.
And the amount of times I thought of what I would do
if I was in there,
I would just slam my fucking head.
I would fuck I do the million dollar baby.
I would bite through my fucking time but it,
but to actually fucking,
you know,
hot,
it'd have to be before I could actually have the balls to do that.
Um,
is there a way to just like,
you know,
you just rip your own throat out?
I would,
I would literally,
I would try to fucking punctured my neck and bleed out.
That's what I would try to do.
Um,
but they probably put you in the butt ass naked with your phone all tied up and
shit.
I mean,
just fucking brutal.
So it's not even a question dude.
65 grand a fucking year in the present.
You know,
my dress like Albert Einstein,
same fucking clothes every day except would be more the Malcolm young wardrobe,
rest his soul.
Do you know,
I've been,
you know,
going through a lot of shit here and I actually found this Malcolm Young,
uh,
like action figure thing that I have not action figure.
It's like e but I bought the thing,
I never assembled it cause you had to came from somewhere in Asia.
So,
you know,
Angus didn't get any money on it and you fucking,
uh,
you got to Gulu his feet to the fucking base.
Uh,
I've been meaning to go over to one of these fucking mom and pop department
stores,
you know,
Fuck Home Depot.
I mean anytime,
like you want to talk about someone who gets to act like a king over there,
she can actually find somebody on the floor.
They can,
that doesn't have 20 people like running after them.
You know,
like when a dog whisperer goes over the hill and he's got $20,
about 20 kids behind them or dogs behind them.
That's what the fuck.
And Home Depot is like.
So anyways,
yeah,
I would take 65.
We're in a year.
Great question though.
Great question.
A great.
Um,
I hope that guy,
I,
it's going to work out for you buddy.
All right.
If you want,
you got to tell somebody first dates.
Tell me about yourself.
Uh,
I've always wanted a Lamborghini,
you know,
Jesus.
What kind of woman would that attract?
Uh,
I dunno,
but that's your dilemma,
buddy.
Good luck with it.
All right,
go fuck yourselves.
I'll check in on,
yeah,
on Thursday.